Speaker 1: Let's go next to Patrick
from Alabama. Welcome, Patrick.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 3: So in light of Herschel Walker
now admitting to two additional children.
Yeah. I was wondering if you had
any advice for Rafael Warnock's
campaign to take the win home this midterm?
Speaker 1: Well, for people who don't know,
Herschel Walker is the Trump endorsed Republican
candidate. He has one son that we all know about,
Christian Walker, who has a sizable social media
presence. And during his campaign, Herschel Walker
has been talking about the scourge or scorch, as
Trump would pronounce it, of absentee fathers,
particularly in the black community. Herschel
Walker himself is black. And earlier this week,
it was revealed that he has one child that he does
not see and for whom he is an absentee father.
And then it was no known that they're actually
multiple others, I think another boy and then a
daughter as well. And so it's another one of these
examples of the allegations or confessions and
projection, and they don't even live by their
own values. I actually think that in a normal
situation, this would end Walker's candidacy, like
in 20 years ago. This would end any candidate, not
but a Republican also, because this is so
against their stated values. But Podrick,
the thing I'm wondering about is, in the modern
Trumpian Republican era, will the Georgia voters
even care about this? So it's really going
to be a test. Now, if you're Raphael Warnock,
how do you take advantage of it? Raphael Warnock
has the benefit of being black himself. And so he
may be able to and I don't know how this would
play. Okay. I'm not giving advice here. Raphael
Warnock might be able to say, hey, you know what?
Herschel Walker rightly identified an issue which
is absentee fatherhood. And I, as a black man,
I don't even know if Warnock has kids. If he has
kids, he could say, I am living the values that
Herschel Walker is saying we should have. He is
not. You got to vote for me. And I don't I'm just
thinking out loud here, you know, but at the end
of the day, I don't really know that it will make
a difference, because if the voters don't care
about what Walker does, as long as he's not a
Democrat, it's not going to matter in the end.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I agree with that as well. I
think it's going to be pretty tough even with
this coming to light for Raphael to pull it out.
Speaker 1: Oh, you think Ralph Warnock's
not going to going to win?
Speaker 3: I think it'll be tough, to
be honest. I think even just with, like you said,
the state of values kind of contradict, I think
we're not going to be tied too much to Biden come
November and voters are going to punish him for it
just because of gas prices. I mean, in the end.
Speaker 1: As of earlier this week, they're
basically running tied. So I don't know,
you know, is that good or bad in Georgia
in June? I guess we'll have to wait and see.
Speaker 3: Right. Gotcha. Well, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: Thank you for the call very much.
Appreciate it. Yeah, that's a that's a really
interesting race. There's there's no shortage
of interesting races, quite frankly. Let's go
next to Nate from Chapel Hill. Nate, welcome. Nate
from Chapel Hill. Please unmute and we'll be able
to talk to each other. I see that you are muted on
your end. You must unmute yourself, sir. And Nate,
last chance to unmute yourself and talk to me.
All right. Nate is insisting on remaining muted.